maybe a different first move and here we
go okay okay all right queen's pawn
opening uh no more english opening that
we saw earlier in uh
in the match so yeah early days in the
world championship match magnus was
relying mostly on the catalan opening
will we see that now is the queen's
gambit declined no catalan it's uh an
opening actually this position was the
one where pragnanda beat
magnus carlton earlier in the prelims
slightly different variation now we see
a quick trade of some central pawns
still very well known territory here the
tarash defense of the queen's gambit
declined i think it was um i think it
was mentioned that this variation was
prepared
for yan by peter lecko
in the world championships with the
black pieces i think this is part part
of that preparation at least
uh the isolated pawn yet again we were
talking about this a lot yesterday theme
of the whole tournament a very big theme
with black having this weak pawn in the
center but also getting uh quite a lot
of activity for that for that isolated
pawn yeah and it was noticeable in the
world championship match that magnus i
think he knew that this was one of the
main lines that napoli would rely upon
but he completely dodged this opening he
avoided it uh he went for something else
in every single game where magnus had
white so there we saw the reason maybe
that white isn't always so happy to
enter this opening is because the white
queen does get kicked about a fair bit
that is one of the compensating factors
for black's isolated pawn
meanwhile jan just looking off to the
side because he's trying to remember
exactly what to do he's studied this
position before he's probably spent
countless hours looking at it as simon
mentioned peter lecko one of his seconds
probably looked at it for hours as well
and okay he brings out the black queen
and this is also very similar to a game
from the world cup between
duda and sam shankland
and that of course ended in a win for
duda okay
oh sorry not soundtrackland it's okay
carrickan that didn't win for duda to
clinch the world cup okay so this is a
popular one then i knew all that just
thought i'd let david say it you know so
i would have chipped in with the with
the you know the dates and
the time and a day but you know
we'll let david say this
i think no no you're absolutely right um
definitely it was definitely this pawn
structure and this opening in that game
and uh
uh queen 4a isn't necessarily the most
popular but it is a line uh certain
grand masters have been playing it
but it's much more popular in fact to
reinforce the protection of the isolated
queen's pawn in the middle and develop
the light square bishop instead so this
is maybe why magnus is taking some time
out to think because
white january tends to play in this
position
to the queen moving to the b5 square so
it offers herself up for an exchange
yeah so there's a lot of pressure right
now on this week undefended pawn and uh
i don't think there's time for white to
get greedy and grab in the center
because black's queen is going to be the
most active piece if this happens if
queen if this black queen takes the pawn
that's why
a queen trade as well just strategically
long term if your opponent has a weaker
pawn structure here an isolated pawn
then it does make sense to trade queens
and earlier simon you mentioned that the
first game the english opening kind of
transposed to a sicilian defense with
colours reversed this is pretty much a
complete transposition to another
sicilian defense with colors reversed
the c3 sicilian just uh here
white of course would be playing the
black side there so black would normally
have an extra tempo
and uh david your memory is recognition
your memory is incredibly impressive as
you just showed have you got any like
bits of advice you could give to improve
your memory uh or your visualization as
a chess player in general because it is
a really important skill so being able
to memorize the work you've done maybe
you know before a tournament or being
able to sort of recall that memory is
there anything that you do that's
special or um
good question i probably should do more
but um i guess one thing that i did when
i was young from a young age is i would
read through books magazines just
without a chessboard and i would play
through the games in my mind and that
just helps with the visualization
um also it made me kind of forced me to
concentrate a bit more so i had to
memorize things yeah and yeah in general
i would advise also playing things
through on the board i mean i love for
example so uh resources like chessable
where you can play through things on the
computer screen you could test yourself
replay it replay it but putting it on
the board just feeling the pieces kind
of is another level of yeah i i'm
actually quite similar i think
uh one of the one of the times where i
really improved was actually uh i'd look
at games look at tactics but i'd look at
it without a chess board so i'd have to
i get a puzzle book famously i'd read a
puzzle book in the bath and that's where
that's don't picture it
yeah
yeah i don't get too excited either um
but that's where i really improved
actually because i was really i had to
like visualize them and solve them and i
tried to solve two two a day in the bath
and um actually that visualization was
yeah it really helped me and i i would
say
don't always use a board it sounds weird
but try to just not move the pieces and
just see in your mind's eye where they
can move and yeah i'm doing about you
you vancouver do you have any bits of
advice there as well yeah i mean i i had
some good bits of advice basically that
when you are doing these kind of
exercises calculation stuff then you
should actually make a note of
everything that you've calculated
because often when you check the answer
you're like yeah yeah yeah i saw that
but you didn't you only saw maybe like a
fifth of the lines and
by holding by writing it down you hold
yourself to account and i can hear some
noises telling me that some moves have
been played
and magnus didn't actually take the
mainstream approach
and instead lifted up his rook to defend
the pawn and now develops completed his
development
yeah so uh very surprising move white's
rook in the middle looks a bit clumsy as
if it might get hit later in the game
but then again it could be a great piece
white's rook on the second ranked
defending pawns and if white does get
the time to castle magnus hasn't castled
very early in these three games we've
seen so far in this final but if white's
king finally does shuffle off to safety
then the other white rope can step
behind its counterpart and it's kind of
fellow rook and the rooks would double
up so magnus spending a bit of time on
the clock it feels like he's trying to
be a bit creative
but it looks like a decent position yeah
both sides doing all the right things so
far yeah this is the kind of thing he
likes doing isn't it i mean he doesn't
really he wants to keep this position
the way it is until he gets castled and
then start pushing uh towards
black's weak pawn in the center of the
board trying to gang up on that isolated
uh pawn there oh wow oh wow wow
fireworks
i like it i love the way jan's playing
today he's he's pushed that pawn in
front of his king opening up his king
very aggressive movement very dangerous
because your king is so weak now but
he's playing so brave today which is
which is great
this pawn push so double edged right
here so double edge and i must confess
that if it hadn't been for napolita or
another grandmaster who had made it i
would have laughed because i would have
been like what are you doing you pawns
don't go backwards you've exposed your
king for a long long time
um
yeah risky risky stuff now uh napoleon
basically has to bank on dynamism to
keep his position stable because if his
pieces aren't active then i can easily
see magnus holding all the trumps like
for instance he's got the
the pawn to aim forward to he's got a
easy hook there on the right side as
david's highlighting um yeah
risky yeah he's walking a tightrope now
and you mentioned dynamism hence
bringing his bishop out trying to create
a pin on this diagonal and uh okay we
have seen white finally belatedly castle
his king that was needed at some point
and now the black knight has jumped in
and this pin
is black gonna profit from it uh the
idea here is that for example if white
tonight gets greedy and captures this
black knight after a trade in the center
white would take back at the very end
the rook would fall to the black bishop
so i don't think white can get away with
capturing yet with his knight at least
you could make an argument for maybe
taking with the bishop and then planting
your knight in the centre of the board
but now black isolated porn has kind of
moved it's
uh okay this is about to happen actually
it's captured in the center and
maybe later in the game black will be
able to join up his pawns and push them
down the board okay this position now
has happened and
big question for yana ponnichi the black
king's still open if you compare it to
white's king white's king is safe as
houses uh right now so you've got to be
a bit careful with black also this pawn
for now is of target
that being said black has the bishop
pair
i'm trying to look for pluses in black's
position if black gets organized black
is doing well but it takes so many moves
to do that and i'm still a bit afraid of
this king being open
this is the first time in the final so
far that napoleon's king has been more
of a target than magnus's
and uh yeah
i don't really like it for yan at the
moment actually i mean this g5 move was
very aggressive and it's nice to see
these aggressive moves but um they can
backfire and um that king as you pointed
out is so weak compared to white's king
i mean you have to keep trying to play
energetically here i guess so can you
move like a rook uh into the middle of
the board to at least try to create some
threats going against that white knight
i don't even know which rook maybe this
one
because of which one either because
otherwise the knight might take the
bishop but this
this could lead to uh well i don't know
i mean you're trying to win a pawn at
least here um i guess white can just
back up that night with the rook though
if you need to double up these brooks
yeah i don't know if white stabilizes
white's gonna be doing well right so
because black's king is always weak yeah
any type of position where the queens
remain on the board when knights remain
on the board this king is a target you
could easily imagine white's knight
later on taking this pawn and jumping in
with some annoying checks towards the
black king so many holes around it
meanwhile as mentioned this guy is safe
although magnus would love an extra move
to just kind of push the spawn forward
as mentioned and give it some breathing
space
uh later in the game so right now lots
of questions for janna ponnechi to
answer in the current position will he
trade off this night will he bring his
rook to the center of the board
computer says 0.0 but this one is still
really imbalanced yeah
and whilst we're waiting for the players
to make a decision i do have an
excellent question from yamberg [ __ ] who
asks us what chess game would you like
to watch as a movie
the one we just saw maybe yeah
that was a good game right so
i remember there's this famous game
between uh ivan chuck and uh josephus
and the story goes there playing it was
when the vanchak was number two in the
world and uh i expect most people at
home noah van chick is a real character
and it was in a playoff it was a
brilliant game but the story goes that
he was winning he threw the game away
he ran outside in the street and he
started screaming you know just ah you
know all that emotion and he's you know
it was i think you could make a movie
about you know that certainly so that's
joseph versus a van chuck
in 1992
february the 4th
sarajevo
street name ruler
can't remember the street name but apart
from that my memory is perfect you need
to work on your memory yeah i hope our
audience fact check this
yeah i have a great question and if you
also have any other chess questions
you'd like to ask us you can tweet us
using the hashtag chestjams or you can
show us some selfies where you're
watching the show from and talking about
selfies i do have to also show you
another selfie um this one is from
zaroya
and uh this is how they're watching the
show show and watch out for the mug
that's all i can say
is it uh the asking mode it's not the
asking mark it is the team howell mug
nice very cool yeah so that was pa uh
zaroya then i guess was part of the team
battle that i recently played on chess24
yeah that was so cool did i play i might
played and you're simon played for my
team i still played for my team
yeah i played my team and i cheered like
crazy
unfortunately i let the team down but
let's not mention that
that was a number that was a super
fun team event i do love those team
events they're so much fun to follow and
more to come on chess 24 twitch channel
in the future
meanwhile a move has been played and
yana ponnichi playing a really risky
option i'm surprised by this i thought
he was just going to get rid of both of
the white knights as quickly as possible
because those were the potential
attackers of the black king black could
have traded off one set of knights in
the center maybe taken one of the other
knights with his bishop instead now
black is attacking that white rook next
to the white king but that rook can
simply move maybe there are options as
well it feels a bit loose by black for
black right now black's queen is
defending everything but
there's a lot of pieces to cover
and white's knight also has the option
at some point of jumping into the f5
square that we mentioned quite a few
times knight takes pawn in some
positions followed by the other
nightclub there's lots of
lots of moves to consider here for
magnus and they all look quite dangerous
again um
you know if you're in doubt you just
move the rook that's attacked you know
you can just keep your position keep
those trumps alive i i just really don't
like jans king at the moment um it's
going to be something which is the
target forever
now the knights have the simple path as
you mentioned this night going towards
the king here
this night going in even at the cost of
some material sometimes right yeah you
can sacrifice just to get through to the
black king yeah um i think i just have a
feeling it's magnus's style as well just
to move his rook out of the way yeah and
there we go i don't think he's gonna
spend too long it's just not practical
spending ten minutes calculating or five
minutes calculating a night jump when
your rook's under fire just get the rook
out of the fray
and uh still an attack incoming most
likely is black's plan to
maybe trade off here and then plant a
bishop in the center of the board just
trying to block these two rooks but this
does allow white tonight to sneak in
if one night gets to the black king i
think it's just going to be game over
somehow just feels so dangerous
yeah i i just don't like black's
position here i i think uh practically
speaking as well is it's often about
king safety
as we're seeing throughout the tour uh
especially at the quicker time it's the
rapid time limit king safety is is often
worth like half a pawn a pawn and um
just compare the king safety here uh
white's king three bodyguards black's
king has one sort of bodyguard uh the f
pawn near it but it's really airy it's
got a lot of
a lot of fresh air rushing in to get it
there yeah oh there you can see a
close-up of the mug is that my face team
yeah team owl
the tea tastes extra better it does and
yeah i know when it kind of came to king
safety you really reminded me of when i
sat down to write my first book
uh on the caracane and i had like these
six elements of middle game chess and i
remember king safety was one of them and
i and i just i remember writing in the
draft like one line keep the king safe
self-explanatory and then i thought
about a bit more and i was like there's
so much more to king safety than this i
mean it's actually talking to your
pieces it's actually anticipating what
your opponent wants to do
it's also thinking about your plans and
so then i was like okay
let's write a little bit more than one
sentence
because it's not that easy
yeah it's not easy it's not no there's
always kind of levels right it's like
your king safety it might be weak but
it's balanced out by other factors more
long-term factors if you survive then
you're just winning
sometimes for example here black is weak
at his own king but if white's attack
doesn't break through then black's got a
fantastic position
i mean if you could pick up that black g
pawn on g5 right now put it back in
front of your king black is better yeah
black has the advantage because the
black bishop is so strong so yeah
there's different levels of it and
napoli actually he's taking a big risk
here
you probably know what i would play as
white here right i mean
harry the h horn of course
i'm just going to try to you know nibble
nibble away maybe try to get a target
over there that's a very sort of
standard way to to to attack over there
i mean it's not it's not maybe terrible
for black because as you that bishop is
a great piece that yan's managed to get
in the middle blocking things up but it
just seems a bit uncomfortable somehow
um yeah i mean knight f5 is the most
aggressive move here trying to go
directly for the king but it might be
quite easy to defend that you're already
attacking with one piece so you kind of
need to get some other white pieces over
towards the black king somehow and uh
it's not actually that easy to do that
at the moment
i mean just visually it looks so
attractive for white but then again as
you mentioned it's all about the rooks
those two rooks worth five points each
worth ten in total dominated by just one
bishop
maybe something clever like queen a3 um
with two ideas trying to go rook b2
trying to bring the queen
via d6 at the right moment something
like that could be a a way to
potentially another idea to try and
improve
i stumbled upon that idea as well just
the same moment you said it because i
was thinking okay well knight takes
night and then how are you going to
activate the rooks and i really like the
idea of using trying to get a rook
around like using the open line but it's
still it's still
not that scary for black after queen a3
it's just
i just feel like when things do open up
in this position it's the black king
well he's gone for the most aggressive
move yeah are we straight in yeah i like
this one though simon
i like to harry the h pawn marching
forward and okay the knight has jumped
and black plays a really sneaky move
attacking the white knight and that's a
pawn sacrifice giving up this pawn and
magnus doesn't take it because this
knight would have been trapped on the
side of the board pretty much now the
night is hit nowhere else to go it has
to step back and this pawn marching
forward would actually trap this white
knight so that was a really sneaky idea
by janupon issue but magnus had of
course spotted it in advance he reacts
instantly after the queen attacked the
knight
very interesting to take the bishop
there yeah i'm always trying to get rid
of this bishop that the light squared
bishop and uh maybe maybe that was a
good time for white to have taken it on
the last move yeah cause i want to get
my queen over we've talked about that
and uh i just want to go queen g4 uh
in this position and okay i've given up
but you know now now i've got the queen
and knight around your king h4 strong
rook takes d3 that that bishop d6 trying
to win the exchange back yeah sometimes
maybe that was
another possibility just to you know the
rooks aren't doing anything let's give
one of them up yeah that's really clever
actually this uh this idea giving up uh
in this position the rook for the bishop
just to
open the position and uh instead magnus
has planted his knight in the center
this is also attractive i guess
not just attacking this pawn which isn't
too relevant right now but more
importantly attacking the central pawn
because it does team up with the white
queen so this point attacked twice only
defended once if that pawn disappears
the black position crumbles right yeah
so okay how do you defend this guy with
black do you defend it i hesitate to
suggest but do you defend it with a pawn
this looks too open
i guess the white queen will just sneak
back with a check and this is a bit
unpleasant
uh i'm not sure how black answers this
you can't even defend it with the queen
because uh so say for instance instead
of defending with the pawn you used to
step the queen one side to the right
uh because
oh you can yeah maybe you can
push forward maybe
at the very minimum grab a pawn over
here and the computer does say that
black only has one move to keep the
balance and this is not an obvious one
black's best move according to stockfish
is to push this pawn forward hitting the
white queen on the side of the board
but
i don't know whether i would find that
that requires some calculation for
example the white queen could move or
white's knight could step back attacking
the black queen you would have to spot
here that you can just move the black
queen out of the out of danger and now
it's a double attack against the white
queen and the white knight
so i don't know if that move is obvious
for a human would you find this simon
every other move gives white a big
advantage
um i don't know if i'd find it but i i i
guess yan has to find it that's the
thing because if you don't find this
move you're just a lot worse and when
you're in these situations you kind of
look outside of the box because you're
forced to you're forced to uh look for
moves you wouldn't normally uh find
because he jan must realize a danger to
his position here and he really won't
want to play that f pawn forwards
unless he absolutely has to uh i feel um
i mean so i i think he'll find it i mean
bet
yeah maybe
what should we bet on because black's
other moves we should mention this is by
far the best this one keeps the balance
uh black's other moves the second choice
there by the computer is to trade queens
i doubt we'll see that happen it's not
jan's style
and even that doesn't force the trader
queen's right can just step back with
his queen and the third choice move by
the computer is to take this pawn but
that looks too greedy as mentioned black
central pawn would fall to the white
knight and after a trade here it feels
like black king is just too open
so uh simon what are we betting for
about this
i think the first drink tomorrow okay
very nice yeah okay so let's go back to
the place will yan find this important
pawn push
he's frowning he's calculating yeah and
he spent a lot of time compared to
normal yan is normally ahead on the
clock and
are you a drink simon
i only drink champagne in my food oh
yeah because that wasn't specified
norwegian champagne that's gonna be
bankrupt
only the best champagne whiskey whiskey
is a good bet whiskey right yeah yeah
yeah whiskey would be good yeah we're
talking one guys
[Laughter]
i'll take anything in norway so yeah i
mean these players the whole day
actually they seem quite close to their
top form yeah yeah i mean they've amazed
me yeah yeah i i assumed the standard be
a uh a lot worse so i've been very
impressed by by how they turned it on
today sometimes it's great sometimes we
see finals where one player is really
firing the other one just struggling to
get into the game but both sides here i
mean it's as if they're two boxes in a
ring one just punching each other
neither side staggering neither side
getting knocked down
magnus shaking his head now as well
i think magnus missed this because
to me this doesn't seem obvious this
pawn push
and uh okay magnus now does he have to
move his queen that is the big question
if the white queen steps away
then black does have a move no more
threats to deal with black has a move to
get organized
so yeah really critical moments already
in the game yeah and uh
talking about this being a great match
um
you i uril says uh which chess game can
be considered the greatest of all time
so um yeah the queen has actually found
itself on the a6 square a bit far away
from the action yeah
and yeah potential queen trades
happening if black steps back with his
queen
if you go
if you push the pawn on then i guess
well i don't know it's critical as well
about your pawn simon the b pawn b pawn
i was thinking just um that's maybe the
obvious move to attack the queen but
there's many options for uh for for
white there so a discovered attack
pushing this pawn forward indirectly
attacking the white queen with your
bishop
yeah simon you're right this is
completely crazy now yeah it's nice very
quiet i mean you can go pawn takes pawn
or rook takes bishop i guess or
something else probably as well takes
pawn counter-attacking against the black
queen or maybe rook takes this one looks
tempting after pawn takes dropping the
white knight back maybe yeah hitting the
black queen black queen doesn't have too
many squares the black queen has to stay
defending her knight so maybe drops back
now you could take this pawn threatening
some night checks
super complicated yep it's about that
the g pawn you mentioned if that black
pawn was back on its starting square
then uh black would be doing very well
in nearly all of these would just be
almost winning in a lot of these
positions but it's all about the black
pawn being very loose and weak
and uh yeah in the current position
we're expecting maybe this pawn push or
possibly this one but either way still
the computer says 0.3 but this one is
wild and
porn pushes galore
napoli actually doesn't care about his
king he is going for white he's going to
try and trap this bishop
this is this is another crazy position
it's such a great game such a great
final uh today it's so exciting the
games and remember we saw the the m
stats before the start of today um
magnus the maybe the lowest number he
had was resource no what was it
resourcefulness yeah wasn't it yeah um
so this kind of strategy from yana
pognati attacking him
makes a lot of sense yeah yeah and this
is the kind of chess we really wanted to
see and we kind of
wished for in the uh world championship
match because this is napoleon playing
true to his personality okay the games
aren't perfect they're making mistakes
but it is a real fight
and uh both sides getting their chances
and now like david mentioned it's a huge
threat in the air
you know black is simply
having so having pushed the f pawn two
squares is going to go one square more
and
what you do what do i do it's actually i
if i was magnus up maybe start to panic
now
because that black's play it's about who
has the easier play as well in the game
of chess who has the simpler plan and
black has a very very simple plan white
doesn't have a simple plan so
yeah it's it's turned turned around i
think and it's the core of that plan for
black to push pawns basically is it that
simple and even trade questions
yeah just keep pushing and attacking and
i do think that a trade of queens would
lead to a really good end game for black
because just look at that bishop sitting
there on d3 is not a great defender
but boy is a great attacker look at it
it's blocking two rooks i honestly don't
know what magnus can play here
as a move because suddenly his pieces
are really disjointed the queen's on one
side the rooks are on one side the
bishops on the other side they're not
really uh
coherently working together um as well
there's another problem i mean maybe
it's time to kind of sacrifice the
material but brook takes bishop takes
bishop is what i'm thinking you've still
got this f4 problem at the end don't you
this is
maybe you have to try it yeah but i
can't can you see a move david i'm
struggling i must say maybe we can get
the stockfish suggestions on the screen
because we here as a panel we're
struggling to find a move for white and
magnus struggling as well okay i'll tell
you what whatever the first choice is
okay i bet you that magnus you can
choose a bag just find it or not to get
your point back
okay what is the first move okay the
choice oh wow this is difficult this is
almost impossible white's best i don't
think you'll find this uh do you wanna
have a pet then
another drink okay okay good man
and uh i'm gonna be so sorted tomorrow
come on magnus play what is it a4 white
so white has to just ignore all the
tension with all of the pieces and push
that innocent looking pawn up the board
we've caught we've crowned her alice uh
but that white a pawn two squares up and
try and break down black structure there
that is come on magnus do it for me
do it for me let's let's make david go
bust do you think
so
i think he will play a4 even though i'm
not sure he will but he's done it he's
found all the moves so far yeah
everything he's always fine he's found
it always but this is how can you play
a4 here i don't i mean because the other
two moves are just crazy as well white's
knight jumping into no man's land to a
square it might get trapped
third choice the third choice move for
white here pushing importance f3 opening
up white's own king
that's not gonna happen surely but how
can you find a4 because i was thinking
black moves the b pawn anyway so you're
you're tempting into moving the b pawn i
mean i like i don't know if any human
could find us but he's not really human
magnus so he'll find it yeah he will
find it that's a true sign of genius if
he plays this movie yeah but i don't
understand why is this move so good me
neither
yeah i don't know either but you know
stockfish does say we'll rely on him no
i mean
no
way
might get you a quarter of the drink
two drinks down
boom
magnus castle find a move like that it
looks like all the players taking place
on another side of the board he just
ignores it all and pushes the pawn that
is insane it's absolutely insane
i don't know
anyone who could find a mood like that
because it just doesn't make any sense
especially with three minutes on the
clock as you mentioned
humans would be panicking it looks like
white is about to just get steamrolled
by the black pawn advance especially
that white bishop about to get trapped
the white knight if the bishop
disappears would also be under fire but
magnus just pushes upon ignoring it all
and uh let's try and figure out why this
move is so classy and uh it's all
because i guess if black now pushes
forward which is what he wants to do
trapping this white bishop
then white's just going to ignore it
white's just going to play pawn takes
pawn and
wow i mean this one is still crazy it
looks like the bishop is pinning
everything to the queen anyway but after
pawn takes bishop magnus can escape by
taking the black knight and any pawn
captures here will just be answered by
white recapturing i mean this looks
super scary black's queen taking this
pawn but
magnus has got it all worked out i think
after a queen check hitting the black
king no matter where the black king goes
there will be more checks or the very
least white can drop his knight back and
block this scary file so magnus he's
worked all of this out the move the
lines i'm showing now on the screen
they're four or five moves deep magnus
for sure has had to see this in order to
survive and uh right now this is a big
threat and as simon mentioned if the
pawn moves out of the way uh for example
pushing forward
is still scary magnus has to i think at
some point just sacrifice and hope for
the best yeah i mean even even that line
is isn't that right it's incredibly hard
to work outside
this move played in this direction yeah
tracking bishop what could be more
natural yeah magnus i expect him quickly
to take this pawn because what else and
right now the black
black is threatening this white bishop
and black is threatening the knight two
pieces under fire white has to counter
attack and he doesn't play
wow knight comes in
and again crazy position uh black's
knight centralized there is tension here
at least now you can save your bishop
maybe you can trade here on this square
and move your bishop because the white
queen at least defends her knight but
this looks super scary black's pawn's
about to march down the board this is
playing with fire the computer likes
white though surprising it's white wow
what's he played he's taken taken that
pawn keeps finding the best moves magnus
yeah he has to save his bishop he has to
park it on the side of the board let's
go back to the players this one
i mean how many people
in the history of chess could find a4 in
a rapid play game i wonder because uh
you know i mean i'm sure obviously
you know lots some people would but i
don't know i mean like a4 is just
incredible not that much time on the
clock no yeah is this
calculating all of those complications
yeah i think if we had an hour maybe uh
then process of elimination we would see
no other moves are working
no other moves seem
logical then maybe we would find it just
because we'd stop looking for other
moves but
to find it in a rapid game
incredible yeah another level and right
now i think white just has to move the
bridge by the way it's attacked by a
porn what else is magnus considering
is he thinking about sacrifice i don't
think there's any reason to bring the
white queen back and give a check yeah
no i was thinking you could try knight
takes pawn and queen check but um
don't even ask me what's happening there
yeah because there's so many open lines
you might be able to get a rook in uh or
or crate
or then bring the bishop around but
moving the bishop straight away just
seems very normal to stop black's rook
also coming to f6 lots of calculators
there's a lot to calculate still yeah
flax pawns i mean if the white bishop
moves black's pawns marching down the
board i think it's okay for white um but
i'm not 100 sure you called it magnus
doesn't go for the safe option right
neither player in the mood for peace
today
at least and uh and
saw it he takes it immediately and now
the queen does come here but mine's
frowning a little bit here ah that's the
check that's
i hadn't looked any further than this
they just just look like there's a lot
of white pieces it's scary for black
suddenly maybe yeah yeah the black king
has to move or you have to block this
check
no matter where you block it if you drop
your knight back the black bishop might
fall if you put the black rook in this
in the middle of this check the white
rook can come up the board
magnus also under two minutes now worth
pointing out and they're both getting to
critical point and it's also worth
noting that obviously that's the first
leg of the final we're playing tomorrow
but if either side wins this game
they've won the first the first bit yeah
so it's a
lot a lot to play for in this game
yeah this is
still so sharp and look at yann's face
yeah he's saying that he's kind of
shocked at this turn of events yeah
maybe he thought he was
i think he's
treated the knight wow
he doesn't look happy does he no he
doesn't well you mean he looks kind of a
bit of a smile there yeah it's not an
ironic smile again possibly knowing dan
he thinks he was probably winning or had
a big advantage and he knows he's let it
slip meanwhile though let's do a quick
count things have i mean the dust is
cleared things have slightly um
clarified and black has an extra knight
but white has three pawns temporarily in
return so that's balanced and knight is
the same as three pawns that being said
the white king's super safe the black
king not safe at all if the queen's come
off i think black is better because the
knight is far
more flexible than the pawns the pawns
are weak as well white spawns but yeah
are the queens remain not easy yeah and
the pawns are also far back you know i
once heard a look a little rule of thumb
when it comes to a piece versus pawns so
a piece versus three pawns it tends to
be a piece is better
unless you have that something else so
it could be like maybe you're gonna
attack against your opponent's king the
pawns are super far advanced and uh two
pawns for a piece tends to be always
better for a piece unless you have like
a raging attack so you need to have
significantly more dynamic factors i
thought was quite a nice little little
rule of thumb that you go for as long as
you have that something else
then go for the pawns and it seems here
that white certainly has something else
because uh he has the open file for the
rooks active queen and a weak black king
so exactly i would take white here i
mean uh i don't understand again the
evaluation bar i've just seen is over in
yan's
yan's half but practically speaking
again it's practical who's got the
easier position to play this is
something you've always got to ask
yourself people don't do this enough who
can which moves are easier to find and i
think you know you can see yan shaking
his head i think magnus's moves are
easier to play right i mean uh you can
bring the queen in the right moment get
the rook to a better square maybe go
rook to block the queen coming back here
looks like a nice idea actually um i
like that move actually move it right
into the middle of the ball because if
you check with a queen in this position
then black will try to go for the ending
that david uh mentioned before just by
bringing the queen all the way back and
that's a very nice defensive position so
you want to stop that maneuver so you
can
block that queen by
moving the rook in the way of that
defensive maneuver and also this
improves the rook because the rook might
want to swing over to attack and this
this looks very scary for black
yeah suddenly the queen is locked out as
a defender right yeah she would love to
plug herself in front of her king but no
longer possible and i think that's maybe
one of the most likely moves the two i
would say are yeah your move simon or
this one that magnus has played right
yeah seventh rank we call it seventh
heaven here it's just yeah i mean
targets for the white rook but also
i mean if at some point it might
sacrifice itself for the night or it
might try and break through on this line
if you could put both of the white rooks
on the seventh rank is just gonna win
for white and also minimal risk this
type of position you mentioned the ease
of position to play even if the queen's
come off if white can trade off these
two pawns i think it's a draw anyway so
um yeah i think white is the one with
all of the cards up his sleeve and black
really backs to the wall defensive job
i'm still surprised the evaluation bar
in the middle and talking about the
seventh rank the seven deadly chess
since uh you can learn now how to avoid
the seven deadly chess ends if you go to
chesapool.com there is a special offer
right now you can get the seven deadly
chest since book and
video valued at 150
for free so use this qr code and get
into chessable to get that
fantastic course a bunch of moves are we
seeing some deadly chess ins here
possibly and uh jan he's just going to
make sure he doesn't commit the sin of
egoism where he just gets carried away
with the position that he could have
been
focused too much on his plans here i
think he just needs to be completely
objective as black and think okay i'm
defending i need to just survive now and
uh
magnus meanwhile switching the play he
went towards the black king with his
queen now he swung the whole way across
the board and now that black pawn
is a big target it might just fall off
the board the black a pawn if it does
white has two avenues of attack white's
b porn is very close to promotion also
the black king as well
as mentioned a huge huge target but the
position has repeated itself i hope
we're not going to see this fizzle out
towards a draw
we might be headed in that direction
all right okay we've seen this position
twice before if magnus brings the queen
across again it's a draw
third time jan's smiling
and magnus says no drama oh he's gone
not for you today
no not today it's not a drawing day
today so and
it's an action day today i just couldn't
believe that offer is it really free
that that seven deadly sins
that's a really good offer i'd say it's
a fantastic but we will we all said how
much of a great book it is and you get
the videos as well yeah sure okay
limited time yeah yeah that's i mean you
know free things are good right
especially they're like great quality
with yeah yeah yeah everyone should get
that nothing better than free stuff
nothing better especially when it's one
of the best i will be saying that
tomorrow while i'm enjoying my two beers
david
i will sip and i'll be like yes enjoy
simon not beers
champagne sorry yeah only champagne i'm
actually checking out the menu at the
good night to try to find the most
expensive
i ever won a bet in the studio i lost
one to you i had to dress up as a
teletubbie i lose bets to ivanka all the
time and they guess the move from
guess the move type of positions in now
slime
i honestly thought that you you had it
in the bag
with simon's last bet but then shocking
one a4 came
and magnus proved that he's a machine
yeah and look at the bar here now you
guys can you go rook to d6 i've just
seen all of a sudden wow what could
could he have gone broke d6 there that
looked quite good actually yeah i mean
possibly maybe we can show this on the
board so magnus's last move very nice as
well he's got some direct threats but uh
simon mentioning that the rook could
just step up the board trying to swing
across and pin the black queen and if
the rook gets captured by the black
knight then rook takes queen and this
position favorable for white queens and
rooks
it's never clear who's are better but
the black king just too open and white
has pawns to push so this would have
been nice as well but magnus he's maybe
trying to be even more ambitious than
grinding out the same game um in the
current position if we catch up the rook
swung across
black's rook leaping to the defense
maybe he's got the same idea in mind
simon yeah if he goes rook f6 here
without um
without allowing that idea we just saw i
mean it's still uh incredibly scary for
black isn't it but
you could just take this pawn as well
okay he has just taken this i mean hang
on a second aren't there like tricks in
the in the air for black has magnus just
committed the sin of materialism agreed
just grabbing a pawn when suddenly as
irvana mentions maybe some ideas against
the white king
for example you could deliver a check if
the king moves then maybe try and get
your queen into the game
uh actually maybe
so complicated here
i was wondering whether you could try
and get this knight in at some point but
you just can't right now
both kings are suddenly a target
suddenly the white king's less safe than
it previously was black wants to get rid
of harry so that you could somehow check
on this file but
not easy
suddenly bar is being on a roller
coaster today isn't it the bar's been
all over the shop had a workout today
he's had a proper workout today yeah
could uh in this position oh no it's not
possible
you'd love to move the night right and
bring it in but uh unfortunately the
night moves
this comes with a check he's got he's
going to bring the queen in
and um
okay that makes sense dispositions yeah
bring the queen in without moving the
rooks i thought queen f6 would otherwise
be a good move but maybe you can't do
that here because the knight e5 will say
wow i mean is that queen coming across
looks so scary but you're right just
move this night out i think so yeah
i'm not sure where you go probably all
of them are fine yeah
hitting the queen hitting the rook in a
skewer
so sharp position i mean still all
through results on the cards yeah magnus
needs to find a move
time situation um it is also worth
pointing out they're both now under a
minute
we're back into the action zone
welcome to the danger zone really
bringing us entertainment in this can
you name the phone
sorry you can't name the film
anyone
welcome that's probably the way i'm
singing it and i probably sang it wrong
welcome to the danger zone
okay is it a danger zone no one can name
the film that's what it is
yeah i was going to say top gun i just
didn't want to sound stupid if it was
wrong
not as cheap as me singing so don't
worry about it
why singing yeah okay what's happening
trying to work out it looks like black
is about to check mate white but not yet
if the black queen slides back to check
the white king from the front white's
rook on the fourth rank can come across
and block
so oh it's hanging by a thread for
magnus suddenly things have turned the
momentum has changed magnus was the one
attacking now it's yan attacking but
there was no breakthrough so the black
queen had to step back
and uh a trade of queens would most
likely result in a draw
white has a lot of pawns for that black
knight white has three pawns for it but
it feels like the black rooks will be
able to stop those white pawns
and magnus can he find anything better
than a queen trade queen trade is the
safe option but we've seen both players
playing for the win throughout today in
every single game be very sad to swap
the queen's off in a way because white's
had this pressure against black's king
for most of the game and
you really don't want to swap the queens
off when your opponent's king
is more airy got a lot more air around
it and it still seems the black king is
probably weaker than the white king and
again five seconds on the clock for
magnus five seconds okay does allow the
queen trade the country does happen but
black now has to defend against a very
far advanced pawn yeah
not easy still for napoli actually and
the white house around 30 seconds white
rooks they're coordinating very well
it's not easy for black to start
mobilizing his knight or his his rook
next to the king for that point
he does activate his knight and magnus
ooh gesturing there shaking his head i
think maybe he underestimated this one
the reason this is fine is because white
doesn't have time now to move the rook
because the black knight is threatening
a deadly check actually if white moves
the rook and the black knight comes to
the g4 square with check that would end
in checkmate even white's king is not
safe wow having all those pawns around
it wow that's incredible actually
maybe you can show oh okay well
obviously you've seen it yeah you saw it
so white had to cover any checking
squares from the black knight that would
have been a really nice pattern maybe
we'll show that a bit later but uh
magnus now pushing pawns on both sides
of the board he's gonna try and
overwhelm uh black's pieces
but it's not gonna be easy
wow who's the star player for each of
these two now who is the maradona in
each camp
i guess that white pawn on the asic
square is the potential goal scorer but
it's under lock and key right now i'm
just seeing from twitter that maybe i
even got the words wrong is it highway
to the danger zone
what did i say did i say welcome welcome
to the dangers yeah oh i love that
that's my version
a little bit i have a friend that always
thinks i am the tiger i am the tiger
it's even more happy
all right well who's the tiger here will
we have a winner will it be a draw at
the moment it looks like two tigers just
balancing each other out
really high level really intense chess
and magnus now just moving his king to
the side does this allow black to go and
capture a pawn with the black rook
ah magnus there we go one pawn drops off
and uh now the knight under fire from
the white rook
yeah magnus knows that the win is no
longer likely
what is most likely to happen is black
giving up the knight for that white a
pawn as we mentioned alice the a pawn
will cost black the knight but not
enough pawns left here we go knight
takes pawn is about to happen
and
the players i think they've just agreed
to a draw yeah we were about to draw
rook and game both shaking their head
again
i mean it's been such a great day and it
takes it to the last game right so we're
shaking